stepping back
wrestling is one of the oldest forms of
combat period
dating back there's cave drawings 15 000
years ago
and if you look at uh the ancient
olympics the greek olympics 2700 years
ago
did you ever when you wrestled or
coached do you now
see wrestling in this way of freestyling
folk style wrestling
the purity of sort of two human beings
locked in combat
the the roots of that us just human
beings
this fair struggle between two men or
two women
i don't think i ever looked at it
as anything but just to a combat
and
i think there's times that have made me
figure out how to make that combat
better
there's little markers
or little points in time in your life
that make you wonder
or i should say determined
to be able to get more out of yourself
and to be able to take it to a new level
and i don't think people can actually
feel that way
unless you've actually had a lot of
accomplishments in anything
i think there's anything out there i
mean no matter what sport
or or breaking the four minute mile i
mean when you broke that
when they broke that roger banister
broke that four minute mile
i can't imagine him breaking it from his
best time being 4
30. you know it's one of these things
that
along the line there that he did
had some close calls or
he had some coaching that was giving him
the opportunity to become a little
better
but i think because he was doing well
and being very successful that the
opportunity came
and so as for me it's like the same
thing i had so much
success and so many practices
that went well and so much
goodness out of this sport
that it gave me the opportunity
to really look more finite
and look more how i can even make it
better and so it's like
if you look at my library upstairs i got
a library upstairs
and there's a lot of books up there
from the family and but if you look at
the gable books up there
i got a lot of russian technique books
[Laughter]
i can't read the book but i can see the
diagrams
and i can see this the figures they
don't really show it in pictures
they do it in drawings and
and so it's like when i was trying to
beat the best
that has labeled the best because
they win the world championships every
year since they've
been just about involved and i don't
think they got started involved until
like the 50s but
but you know it's something you know you
study the best who's out there but then
you
don't focus so much on the best
that you can't beat the best you learn
from them
but there's something that they don't
have
that you can have toughness to technique
to the art to the science yeah all that
stuff and that's why
even talking to you when you're sitting
over there you love mit
and you're bragging about it over
harvard you know
you know it's cause it's true in your
eyes and
and that's and that's great and it might
be but but
it's the same type of thing that uh
you know there's something that you're
probably stealing from harvard
but you won't give them credit
you